in the hunger games as well as Game of
Thrones these are two very intense loyal
passionate fan bases have you noticed a
difference between these two fan bases
yet is one more intense than the other
they pretty much tied there pretty much
as passionate as each other they're
pretty much tied I went to comic-con for
the first time in San Diego back in July
and was oscillating between the two
casts and the fans are pretty 50/50 in
knowledge passion support social media
hype is pretty cool I'm a lucky girl
right now yeah well I would think
there's a lot to know for Hunger Games
but the amount of knowledge you have to
have for Game of Thrones you may not
know all that stuff there are times
where someone I think was george RR
martin gave me he was here and i was
interviewing him he gave me my own
laminated sheet family tree of all
everybody relates to each other and
there have many times do i keep it under
a pillow and i'm watching the show and
you know and i'm looking but you know i
would think it must be difficult for you
to keep track of all of that yeah i
don't bother you've put me in my place
and I deserved it Hunger Games your
character is a badass yes she's pretty
cool she's very cool she's pretty Punk
grieving yeah yeah we have a picture
here of Cressida and man I love the
hairstyle I love the tattoos and you are
quite athletic and I understand in real
life you are a fantastic runner well
when we were shooting when we were
shooting we we shot the two movies
back-to-back Mockingjay part 1 and part
2 together and so we were 9 months
shooting and I was training for the
London Marathon at the time so that
really helped because like a
semi-automatic rifle lake is quite heavy
but I'm quite physical and I really
enjoyed the cardio demands it's more in
the second movie than the first maybe
I'm more with the camera you have to
wait a year for the gun guys but um
right no it was really useful that I
love running and um I am quite physical
have you always been a good runner yeah
I've always been a bit of a tomboy I I
know I don't look it right now but I
there's a whole team back there that
makes me look like this I'm always
I have a team - you don't just get this
all eyes are on me right now your face
fell after you said that you know I ran
the London Marathon back in April and it
helped that the training coincided with
the stunt work of Mockingjay yeah
you